the Joe Rogan experience it's good news
I'm an optimist yeah yeah 100%
glass-is-half-full yeah yeah have you
ever tried to turn other people into an
optimist and been successful no I don't
think I think it's real hard to turn a
battleship yeah I mean if I've made a
incremental push in the direction I've
moved in one or two degrees to the right
over time maybe it'll change their
direction but the reality is you got to
want to change yourself and sometimes
someone's inspirational words could be
the thing that you needed and that sets
you off on a good path and then you do
make change but for the most part when
someone comes to you and tells you you
have to change it's really hard for
people to accept just like you were
talking about in your episode on
changing your mind right which I really
loved but I'm sure that a lot of people
who've listened to this podcast or who
watch this podcast have you know drawn
in the both the explicitly specific
reaction with them right I haven't
having a specific interaction where I
got them to change changing because
they're hearing me but they're also
probably hearing a million other people
they're hearing David Goggins and
Cameron Haynes and you know fill in the
blank all these different people that do
incredible things and they go why I
gotta [ __ ] do something with my life
I gotta get my [ __ ] I gotta stop
drinking soda
I gotta stop doing this I got a you know
I got a just just starting healthy
taking vitamins maybe one workout class
a week just one start with yours also
though I guess a danger I don't mean to
be a downer because I'm an opportunist
I'm an optimist too but the downer of
the danger potentially is that and this
relates to suicide so you know suicide
is a little bit of a mystery because
it's such a tragic thing if it affects
someone that you you knew or even you
know even people you don't know it just
seems like such a drastic solution to a
problem that is hard to imagine right
but if you look at suicide rates through
history and around the world there's a
lot of variance but there's one trend
that's pretty strong which is suicide
rates tend to be higher in countries
with more prosperity which would seem
nuts right
you would think that if your life is
kind of very very difficult on a kind of
Maslow's hierarchy level right not
enough to eat worried about paying ran
or being safe that you'd be more likely
to be suicidal but it turns out it's
it's generally the opposite not always
and what one suicide ologist deduced
from that or the kind of theory that he
came up with it's he calls it's the no
one left to blame theory of suicide
which is if you live in an environment
where let's say you've got a spouse
that's cruel to you or you've got a
terrible work situation or you live
somewhere where the government is
repressive whatever you can always kind
of see a light at the end of the tunnel
and you can say that you know when that
problem is done my life will get better
but if you live in a society like ours
where you've never had to worry about
having enough to eat you've never gone
too cold or too hot where you're
surrounded by prosperity and you look
around at everybody else and like
they're not depressed and you think what
is it it's me the no one left to blame
theory and that's one argument for why
there's like right now is a lot of teen
and young people suicide in a country
like America where the riches are the
prosperity is boundless
have you read Jonathan hates work yeah
yeah so his take on that is that these
kids are experiencing social media and
they're experiencing this addiction to
the Internet and this cruelty that they
experience the bullying the meanness the
coldness and that when it's targeted at
on people and when they're losing their
position in the social chain and they
feel left out they don't have the tools
to cope with this they're developing
minds and this is the reason why you're
experiencing this uptick that's directly
correlated to the invention of the
iPhone and the invention of smartphones
the invention of social media
applications there's there's all sorts
of correlations where you see the
inventions of these particular things
that have changed everything and then
you see the uptick yeah particularly the
girls will take you with girls and
suicide and you see them trying to keep
up with the Joneses and this this
feeling that they're inadequate or the
judging themselves against girls that
are you know supermodels that are
photoshopped and
feel inadequate I hear Jana that we have
to be careful about correlations proving
causation because it's really tough
because I totally hear you on it it
looks like if they both travel together
Yeah right
on the other hand history is full of
correlations that looked good you know
we were talking about polio the vaccine
earlier polio for reasons that are still
not understood by the way because they
never really figured out the disease
they just figured out a vaccine they
never figured out what caused the
disease but it turns out that polio
would always spike in the summer time so
there were a lot of theories maybe had
to do with being outdoors so parents
would keep their kids indoors maybe it
had something to do with swimming pools
people keep it out of swimming pools but
then there was one theory that what else
happens in the summertime that doesn't
happen in the wintertime ice cream
consumption so there was a theory for a
while that olio was caused by ice cream
on paper the correlation looks pretty
good so I'm saying look Internet and
depression and suicide are a little bit
more complicated than ice cream and
polio but it's hard to tease out effects
for sure no you're right but it's also
hard to ignore the effect of social
media on people's self esteems people
are addicted to phones people are
addicted to likes it's a real occurrence
it's also been engineered in order to
attract the most eyeballs and the best
turns out the best ways to get you
outraged
I agree but again just to bang the same
drum again and again where there's
agreement with you
where there's costs you got a look at
the benefits and this is what I hate
about politicians is they'll talk about
a policy that they like they ignore the
costs they talk about the opponent's
policy they ignore the benefits so with
social media for instance I know a kid a
boy who was a friend of the family who
if he were born thirty years earlier and
there were no way to connect with people
other than in person or phone whatever
he would had a very disconnected life
yet he just had some issues with with
doing that with kind of in person he was
kind of you know behavior that's a
little bit on the spectrum just would
have been very difficult as it turns out
because of the digital revolution he was
able to build a community that is
unbelievably good for him are there
downsides to these things absolutely but
you know you got to look at the benefits
so I do I
and I know I don't I mean we're adapting
I think human beings are adapting to a
new normal and the new normal is
constant connection with all the people
around us all the time if we so choose
to engage leave our fun so choose the
problem is when it becomes more invasive
than that right now it's if we so choose
to engage but if we get to some point
where we're wearing something that right
transmits stuff into our brain or where
someone's wearing us or if you don't if
you don't do it then you can't be a part
of this corporation because we're about
succeeding and this is the best way to
succeed is to connect yourself to the
network to uptick your bandwidth so that
you can keep up with us come on Steve
what's up you know I mean it's team
let's go team you know and then next
thing you know you're wearing the
[ __ ] hat the headband that Ari are
you optimistic about the future in a
general way though people are awesome
great time to be alive I love it I love
people how only a lot of people love
people
[Applause]